all right well now let's wrap up our
Mother's Day celebration and
heartwarming style every Friday we get
to see how much family means to Donnie
Wahlberg on Blue Bloods and their season
finale is tonight on CBS but you shall
turn to found out that the family
bonding has on the show is nothing
compared to the real-life bond Donnie
has with his mother Alma there's this
long-running I don't I don't want to
call it a debate but I guess it is about
who's the favorite kid I already know
she's got to be politically correct but
I already know no no well the
competition is kind of tough when you're
one of nine kids and Mark Wahlberg's
your baby brother ah literally that
Felice because I how could I not be your
favorite look at that face it's easy to
see why Donnie calls himself a mama's
boy
this woman single-handedly raised him
and his siblings while on welfare I had
to learn how to make meals out of
nothing would go to the Salvation Army
store and buy shirts and different stuff
the Wahlberg's have come a long way
since then and with the family's reality
show Wahlburgers --zz miss Alma herself
has become something of a celebrity
yesterday I was in the market I didn't
think I was gonna get out I'm serious
they're taking my picture in the market
and any new kids on the block fan can
tell you she's been there for Donnie
from the very start we first met her 27
years ago when she and the other new
kids moms actually answered their son's
fan mail Donnie came from a family of
nine children and was the second
youngest so he usually wore his brothers
hand-me-down sneakers do you think about
like holy cow
where we've come from and where we are
now and you ever sit back and think
about that her messages to us were
always just to be a good person she
would remind us not just in words and in
deeds
you know I remember I bought her a fancy
bracelet for Christmas one year and she
turned around and pawned it and got
gifts for all of her grandkids you she
was like what am I gonna do with this
fancy fancy bring Slithe to this
day I only Krishan even jewelry and
somebody will say to me whoa we all that
ring is gorgeous I said yeah I was $29
we're only a reflection of her you know
mark and I get all the glory for being
so successful but you know that's all
superficial it really is you know it's
it's who are you in here and who I am in
here I got from her